the gyro can experience when you're
talking about the end of Moore's law
what what is the limitation that we're
facing
technologically like why is it going to
why are there going to be a point where
they can't get any more powerful so the
way I the chips work is you have these I
am you know they wind up sketching out
basically wires onto the silicon chips
and they have gotten so small that the
wire that the currents flowing through
is a handful of atoms wide which is just
astounding if you think about it you
know these are these fundamental
elements of matter and the wire is the
small integer number of atoms wide now
in theory you can keep going down and
say well maybe we can make a one atom
wide electrical path but you wind up
running into eventually all these
quantum effects where if you make a very
narrow wire and you pack them very close
together you have two wires they're an
electron won't necessarily stay on that
one wire of conductor that you want it
to be on because of the way I quantum
mechanics work it is going to wind up
jumping they call it quantum tunneling
there is a percentage chance and quantum
is all about randomness like that but an
electron flowing here there's going to
be this chance that it just teleports
essentially to a nearby wire it takes
this discrete quantum jump to another
wire and this is reality it's shocking
it's not intuitive people have a hard
time kind of grasping a lot of this but
quantum tunneling is a real thing and we
are bumping into quantum limits they can
still shrink more than we are right now
where we're down at 7 nanometers in the
latest ah stuff although there's all
sorts of issues with marketing's speak
about exactly how they measure it but
they're still getting smaller and
there's still room to get smaller still
but the end is in sight it can't go too
much and one of the things that becomes
an issue is just the economics of it
each generation has gotten more and more
expensive if you went back I am thirty
years there were a whole bunch of
semiconductor places that could fab I'm
you know different chips you could go
ahead and have a design and you could
shop it out to a whole bunch of
different places find the one that
worked best for you but it's come down
to the point now where it cost billions
of dollars to make a new fab
and at the high-end process as you're
left with just DSM C Samsung and Intel
I'm very few companies you know AMD held
on for a while until they spun theirs
out I and it's it's so expensive and it
that's one of the challenges where they
will have full confidence that we'll see
a couple more node shrinks
I am so it'll still make chips cheaper
somewhat faster more cores on them but
it is going to get an end of the line
but I hold out hope for potential other
things you know there are directions
that you know maybe you have your carbon
nanotube wires or you're starting able
to be able to do some things with
photonic processing in different ways
there are possible outs for it but I
don't know that any of them are sure
enough thing to really be counting on at
this point it's so hard for a dummy like
me to wrap my head around that but when
you're talking about these wires so if
these wires it's size dependent when
they get too small then this quantum
tunneling becomes completely
unpredictable so it is so I if you draw
out like a probability density function
of like you've got a particle and you
like to think about particles as being
like this hard little billiard ball
that's sitting here in this specific
place that's sort of they you know the
vision that you used to see in grade
school textbooks about here's an atom
you've got these billiard balls in the
middle surrounded by the electrons
moving around but in actuality they're
really these I these distribution
functions they it sounds so weird but
they have a chance at being in all of
these different places and this is not a
curve that goes to zero there is a
nonzero chance that a given atom you
know could wind up being a macroscopic
distance away but there is a real chance
that it could wind up being a few atoms
away so the you know the electron moving
around at the edge of this wire if it
just says well I've got some chance of
being over here and if you've got
billions of these or quadrillions
probably of electrons moving around in
this even if it's a small chance
eventually it's going to jump over there
and enough of them jump over and all of
a sudden you've got a wrong bit you've
got a mistake so we start fighting all
of that by doing error correcting codes
and doing ways that there's this whole
set of technology about how you work
with unreliable systems which starts
getting starts it should start
can you feel a little bit uneasy that
okay we're gonna have this error rate
but we're going to buy this carefully
crafted codes allow ourselves to
constantly be failing constantly having
errors and still getting the right
answer in a statistical enough case now
there's a lot of things like the way
your cell phone works with the way the
radio signal is I interpreted there's a
lot of things that do work in this sort
of probabilistic way but when people are
used to computers as being this accurate
thing where you always get the right
answer that sense of moving to something
that has a larger chance or is a more
probabilistic computation still feels a
little bit sketchy in some ways
[Applause]